my name is markiplier and welcome to
super hot I loaded up the game and it
came to this screen here and now I have
to type something you what okay I didn't
I didn't do any of this
I didn't none of this none of this at
all okay
well then good I'm glad I'm glad that oh
okay just press enter launch super hot
crack and see for yourself
woah this is really interesting now
super odd I played a while ago and it
was like a UH like a proof-of-concept
sow thing where time only moved when you
were moving and I have no idea okay what
the hell is happening there so cool okay
I'm a clicking and the game was so good
the time only moves when you move a
little bit I'm gonna stop freaking out
about it because super super hot super
I'll hold a space to rewind hope this is
like a mind trip grab the gun okay yes
oh sorry I accidentally shot the gun did
not mean to do that
I mean time moves a little bit when you
don't move but very slowly it was except
what was a setup
okay oh so cool okay I need to stop
freaking out because I don't mean to
freak out about things that are really
cool but when I enjoy something it's
ludicrously cool so the basic concept
post game came out about a year ago and
then it was a Kickstarter that funded it
and now this is the beta so this is like
it's something new and fresh and
interesting about it
take it slow exactly okay and you can
see why like yes this beta isn't
available for everybody so I'm sorry if
you can't play yeah but you should
definitely think about like funding the
full game because this is awesome
this is like a really interesting thing
whoa throw your gun whoa oh my goodness
I destroyed his face I took his gun
that's so cool that's so cool
I mean I'm like it I'm a sucker I'm
sucker for interesting concepts I'm a
sucker for style in this movie Oh got
that one it's so
oh I'm trying to actually come up with
like human ideas and stuff in concept
that I could talk about during as I'm
playing this so I'm not just come with
us
there we go that was my first step how
about no thank you take that take that
son more there
okay there we go it's taking a lot of
intense concentration will admit goddamn
the variations between the speed is like
very jarring no ammo how about a little
bit did not freak out about this because
it's little admittedly this is
unbelievably cool and and when I was
equally blown away back when I first
played the original and well the
original was just a proof of concept it
wasn't even really it whoa okay that was
a lot of numbers I didn't catch those
okay didn't catch that either if you go
a little bit slower than I'll be over
here freaking out you don't mind I'm
gonna be losing my mind okey-dokey then
what did you have everybody gets
something different Oh remember every
okay that was just a tutorial I bet oh
man super hot dot exe what about the
story ah finished story mode - unlocked
score ten more kills to unlock okay so I
just got to go through it again I'm
totally fine with that this game is
awesome I'm more than willing we read
okay here we go I'm gone I'm done for
doing it again yes please
Pam I was a setup bang on bang oh man I
kind of want to just beat them beat
their faces in with my bare hands
I know oh I know I know everything I do
is super hot I remember back when I
played the first one I was amazed by it
and I was actually fascinated by the
idea that this game hasn't been tried
before through your gun got that done
and done who's next
anybody want to dance dance
there we go okay there we go and like
the idea that this concept had not been
fully explored before but now I see like
this is like a complete evolution on the
subject and is really really ludicrously
cool like the idea behind it is is cool
by itself but I really like the way that
they improve the styling of it because
the styling of it is like everything
about this game is its just like absurd
like invests a lot of brainpower into
life understanding exactly where things
are going and how things are moving like
the response of everything that I'm
seeing in front of my face and it's just
really it's okay so it left me here
before but I didn't see why okay those
were more numbers those were different
than before I think they are the
monolith so bizarre there's a mystery to
be solved here there is a mystery to be
solved okay
so there's a lot of okay so there's
other things here there's like an app's
folder
it says demos sinus one I don't know
what though okay super okay I don't know
what that means I don't know what's
going on this is like a meta game within
the game that's so bizarre why why is
this here
oh okay it's just a bunch of the logos
to Barratt super odd zoo Barratt super
odd okay and whoa I don't know what
that's all about that's not saying super
hot okay is there like a reason to this
there's got to be like a reason to this
there has to be a reason
otherwise why would they have any this
like so much here why would they have
this all here there's got to be like a
mystery here there's gotta be life is
that what life is supposed to be reminds
me of the zombie apocalypse simulator
that I played whoa hey what's it doing
oh boy sand oh boy I'm literally
watching sand oh man click tap it oh oh
I can play these games these are things
that I can play okay I can make pop-ups
okay cool
why in the world why the world why is
this here why is it all here it's like
some matrix insanity oh man
art hot dot art oh that's art oh man
wait okay
i'm a DC video okay secret oh boy I
found a secret private really yes
horned optics sure aw come on I'm gonna
get it okay finally whatever random
hypno do-it-yourself click for mind
control oh oh so that is the mind
control that's what you're saying that's
Helen that's mind control right there I
see I see how you do me dot argue you
your art here oh I got it okay
videos yes dot Evie what is that well
let me lock it out here okay weird
trailer oh oh it's the whole trailer
made in ASCII
why these people are completely fine
they are just enjoying a new exciting
video game video games have been
scientifically proven to improve
problem-solving and motor skills spatial
awareness social skills hence justice
control though it takes just 10 seconds
to play this game brings an endless
competitive Entertainment to you your
your family and your friends parties
this game is available now for everyone
to enjoy all you need is that telltale
telephone and some cardboard
and remember play responsibly and don't
mix with drugs
those weird that okay okey-dokey then
okay so there's another mystery to be
solved here that III need a little more
time to be able to figure out so there
it might just be the debate it doesn't
go very far but I think that there's
something else here there's something
hidden in the code here that would allow
me to get a little farther because it
all relies on me finishing story mode
and there's something that happens at
the end of story mode and there's for
some reason the chat that I'm with the
other guy is probably like the series
and numbers I have to input that but I
don't know I'll figure it out in the
next video if you guys want to try to
help me out try to decode a mystery
write in the comments what you think
this means write in the comments what
you think about this game write in the
comments how cool this game actually is
so there's a lot here when the game gets
fully released I imagine it's going to
be really cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching check out my original
video super odd way back when in the
annotations over there in the
description and as always I will see you
in the next video
Oh what am I gonna do about